من الشائع مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء عندما
تصبح الايام ابرد واكثر قتامه الاصابه
بحاله من الكابه الشتويه او ما يعرف
باكتئاب بالشتاء لكن يبدو ان هناك ما هو
اخطر وهو الاضطراب العاطفي الموسمي فاا
وفقا لمن تلهف امريكا يعاني نحو 5% من
الاشخاص من الاضطراب الموسمي السنويا وهو
اضطراب ينتج عن انخفاض ساعات الضوء وزياده
ساعه الظلمه وتسبب هذه الحاله انخفاضا في
المساجد وانعدام الرغبه في القيام بانشطه
يوميه ويمكن ان تشمل الاعراض نقص الطاقه
صعوبه التركيز مشاكل النوم اضافه للشعور
بالحزن والوهن كذلك التغير في الشهيه وخير
ما نسالهم عن تاثير المواسم على النفسيه
وعلى الشخصيه من يعيشون في بلاد الشتاء
والبرد زميلنا ومراسلنا في موسكو منورنا
موجود معنا في الاستديو اليك على الجواز
بما ان الكلام عن اكتئاب الشتاء ها انا
انتقلت من موسكو الى استوديو صباح العربيه
بحثا عن القليل من نور الشمس والقليل من
الدفئ دفء الطبيعه في الخليج العربي ودف
الزمالك في هذا البرنامج ولكن لنتكلم
قليلا عن شتاء موسكو تخيل ان تمضي شهرا
كاملا مع ست دقائق فقط من سطوع الشمس نعم
ست دقائق فقط وهو رقم قياسي تاريخيا سجلته
موسكو في شهر ديسمبر عام 2000 2017 وغياب
الشمس قد يكون اكثر ما يفسر غياب
الابتسامه عن محيي الروس اضافه الى
معتقدهم الثقافيه الراسخ بان الضاحكه من
دون سبب من قله الادب لكن القصه تتعقد
اكثر فاكثر فما ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض
لا تختفي الغيوم بل يختفي الثلج وهنا
القصه حيث يؤكد العلماء ان الثلج جاي يمكن
ان يحد من قساوت غياب الشمس لانه يعكس
الضوء
لينشر النور وينشر كثيرا من شظايا الفرح
في موسم الكابه روسيا شانها شان باقي شعوب
البلاد البارده تعاني من الاكتئاب وتعالج
الدقه بالدواء حين وبدائي احيانا وبين
الداء والدواء يستعيد اهل موسكو شيئا من
ادبي دستيفكي ويتذكرون قوله كل مظهرت
الشمس ان تعيش من دون امل هو ان تتوقف عن
الحياه او بالاحرى كما يقال بالروسيه
[موسيقى]
قدم اخصائيه الصحه العقليه بعد نصائح
لتحسين نفسك في اشهر الشتاء من التراب
العاطفي الموسمي اولها السماح بدخول اشعه
الشمس فحتى عندما تكون ايام رماديه
وبتجهدا للسماحي بدخول الضوء وافتح اي
ستائر للسماحي بدخول اكبر قدر ممكن منه
استخدم العلاج بالضوء عبر مصابيح اس اي دي
وهي عباره عن ضوء اصطناعي يمكن ان يخدع
الدماغ لاطلاق مواد كيميائيه تعزيز الحاله
باردا ومظلما قد يكون من الصعب العثور على
الدافع حدد اوقات محدده للقيام بالانشطه
وحاول تضمين الاخرين حتى يصعب التراجع
عنها في اللحظه الاخيره حافظ على ممارسه
الرياضه لتخفيف من التراب العاطفي الموسمي
فعند ممارسه الرياضه يفرز جسمك
الاندوررفين والذي بدوره له تاثير ايجابي
على مزاجك التزم بنظام غذائي صحي ومتوازن
هذا يعد خطوه ايجابيه يمكنك اتخاذها
للتحكم في الاضطراب العاطفي الموسمي فاكد
ايضا من شرب كميات كافيه من الماء طوال
اليوم للحفاظ على نشاطك
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه في روسيا
عبد الجواد الراشد الجواد منورنا يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك
صباح العربيه
الجو بالخريف بالذاتها يعني الخريف هو
جميل
وروسيا مع او فول لايف تطلع معنا وانت
مبتسم وروحك كلها ايجابيه هل تعلم الناس
كيف يتعايشون يتاقلمون مع برد الشتاء
البشمه هي مرتبطه بالعربيه على فكره
وبالذات بصباح العربيه سهام نعم بالفعل
الروس اتاقلموا بشكل كثير طبيعي مع الثلج
وفي بعض من هون حول الثلج للجليد والجليد
حولوه له بيوت يعني لما بتروحي شمال شرق
روسيا سيبيريا الحراره ناقص 50 وناقص 60
بتلاقي بيوت من الثلج بيجيبوا الثلج
بيدقوه بيعملوه بقوالب كبيره بتصير هيك
عباره عن عن علب بيعملوا منها بيوت وبتكون
دافئه بعض الشيء نعم بالفعل يعني الرؤوس
حولوا السباحه العاديه لان احنا بنعرفها
بالبحر وبالشمس لا السباحه بالمياه
المتجمده بتلاقي درجه الحراره الجو ناقص
20 بموسكو بتلاقي شاب وبنت ماشيين ماسكين
ايس كريم
حتى يعني ضيوف اللي بيجي على موسكو
يلا يلا معلش
البرد
بيلعب دور كبير بتاسيس الحياه الروسيه
يعني في حروب خاضت الشعب الروسي عبر
التاريخ ومن الحرب العالميه الثانيه واحد
الهزائم يعني اللي تعرض لها للجيش
الالماني هي كانت بسبب برد موسكو القارس
البيوصل لبعض الاحيان لناقص 40 ناقص 36
تخيلي سهام بنقطه الاخيره يعني موسكو
بتمشي بالسياره تقريبا ساعتين بتوقف خمس
دقائق لا تشتري شيئا ما بترجع بتحمي
السياره من جديد
ونسال الدكتور منور
يسعد صباحك سمعت عبد الجواد منورنا اليوم
جاي من مصر الى دبي 5% من الناس يا دكتور
يعانون من الاكتئاب الموسمي
هل فعلا الفصول تغيرها لها تاثير على
نفسيه
صباح الخير سهام صباح الخير على العربيه
المشاهدين مستمعين ومتصفحين
الدبريو اوترا كسباجين عبد الجواد اهلا
وسهلا بك في المنطقه الدافئه من العالم
اييي 5% واكثر يحدث معهم هذا الشيء لانه
احنا دايما ننظر الى الجزء المتطرف اللي
يبدا الناس يعاني منه ويطلب المساعده اللي
هو الطلب المزاج الموسمي ولو معظم الاحيان
يسمى الاكتئاب الموسم لكن في انواع من هذا
الاضطراب قد تكون اقل حد قد تصل الارقام
بعض الاحيان الى 10 واكثر من 10% من
الاشخاص وهو مشكله بالتاكيد هو مشكله يمكن
لا نعاني منها كثيرا في مناطقنا او لا
ننتبه عليها كثيرا في مناطقنا لكن في ارض
الغربه اللي يسكنها همم استاذ عبد الجواد
تكون واضحه جدا ولذلك تشوفي العلاجات
ابتدات من السويد من قرب ال- همم الدائره
القطبيه وتعممت على العالم في همم علاج
اضطراب المزاج الموسم طيب دكتور في بلدان
روسي مثلا يطول فيها فصل الشتاء في هذه
الحاله كيف هو الحل لمنع تحول الاكتئاب
الموسمي الى اكتئاب كحاله مرضيه
هو عشان اتشخص الاكتئاب الموسمي مش مجرد
انخفاض في المزاد لازم ان تظهر كل اعراض
الاكتئاب المعروفه من ضمنها انخفاض المزاج
وانخفاض الفعاليه وزياده الوزن والتراب
انهم كل هذه الاشياء اللي ما تتحقق على
موسم المتتاليه مش من اول مره لذلك ينصح
الاشخاص دائما بالعلاج بالضوء لان هو اسلم
انواعه واقل تاثيرا لكن انواع معينه من
الضوء يعني ما يجوز انه يفتحوا الفلورسنت
ويقعدوا تحته لانه كميه الحراره ممكن تؤذي
الجلد وتؤذي القرنيه هم في انواع معينه من
الضوء النشاط المنتظم مهم جدا التزام
بروتين العمل الرياضه والتعرض الى الشمس
البقاء ضمن دائره اجتماعيه مفتوحه ثم عدم
التردد في طلب المساعده من المختصين نفسنا
وحتى من معالجين نفسيين اذا تطور الامر
واصبح حيث يؤثر على وظائف الشخص او تكرر
اكثر من مره بعد اصبح معيق للمصابين في ان
يقوم بحياتهم العاديه
يطلب المساعده منك يا مختلط
دكتور اسامه
دكتور لو سمحت سؤال يعني احنا حدا مقيم
بموسوا يعني لا عشرات السنين يعني الاطفال
بياخذوا فيتامين دي يشيل اللي بعوض عن
الشمس لكن على العموم يعني رغم فنجان
القهوه الصباحي بتلاقي ان الوضع شوي متازم
بتلاقي الوجوه عابسه بعض الشيء يتخيل
دكتور لما بتفتح محطه المترو الساعه
السادسه صباحا بتلاقي الاشخاص ماشيين
باتجاه المترو مثل الرجل الالي اعطينا شيء
خلطه سحريه دكتور لهذا الموضوع كيف نتعامل
معه
انا بس احب اذكرك انه القمر هو مش مرتبط
بالبرد قد ما هو مرتبط بغياب الشمس لذلك
نفس الاعراض تلاقيها عند البريطانيين
البريطانيين المتجاهلين بسبب وضع الجزيره
هناك وانه الشمس قليل وجودها في سماء لندن
ولذلك البريطاني يعرف عنهم انهم دائما
وجوههم وعصبيين بعض الشيء لكن في حالات
اللي وصفتها حضرتك اللي خلينا نقول دول
اسكندنافيه اكثر الدول
درستها كانت الرياضه شيء مهم الغذاء
المتوازن شيء مهم مثل ما قلت انت تعويض
فيتامين دال لكن انا احب اشير الى شيء انت
قلت في تقرير مرور سريع ولم ينتبه عليه
احد انه بعض الاشخاص يحاول ان يعالج هذا
الشيء بشيء اكثر غرارا في في موسكو لما
يشعروا بالبرد يلجؤه الى الكحوليات لتدفئه
لكن هذه تكون ماساه جديده لذلك احنا ننصح
دائما الاشخاص انه التزم بروتين من
الرياضه حاول ان تزيد الاضاءه اللي حواليك
التزم بمجموعه من الفعيات الاجتماعيه اللي
اتذكرك باهميتك واهميه الاشخاص اللي
حواليك اذا وجدت انه القمر خرج عن السيطره
فلا تتردد نهائيا بطلب المساعده بعض
المشوره بعض الاحيان تكون كافيه جدا وبنفس
الوقت اذا احتاجت الى علاج يجب ان تتعالج
اللي حدث مع الرؤوس كمان شويه مختلفه
لانهم بطبعهم شويه يتحملوا عندهم مورونا
اكثر من الاخرين لذلك ما يظهر عليهم مثلا
اعراض شديده للاكتئاب مثل اللي يحدث في
الدول الاسكندنافيه المدلعين شويه لذلك
تشوف حتى الدراسات تحاول تستفيدهم على ان
هي جزء من طبيعه الشعب الروسي مش انه هي
حاله مرضيه اما بالنسبه لك طبعا لا
الرياضه مهمه جدا بالنسبه لك
اه فعلا صحيح يا دكتور خلاص الحل الوحيد
هو انه يجيك على الرياض طبعا
جميله عبد الجواد الرشد شكرا